Peter Parker spends his time in "No Way
Home" trying to send the multiverse's
villains back home – but what happens in
their worlds once they get there? And wait,
when exactly are they coming from? These
confusing moments, and more, explained next.
"No Way Home" opens at exactly the point where
"Far From Home" ended. A breaking news report
from the Daily Bugle's incorrigible J.
Jonah Jameson reveals two key pieces of
information to the world: Spider-Man is
Peter Parker, and he killed Mysterio.
It's no surprise, that Mysterio was
able to capture footage of Peter to
be released after his death, but
how exactly did the villain manage
to convince the world that Spider-Man had
murdered him and unleashed a drone army?
Right from the start, there were some major flaws
in Mysterio's posthumous plan. For one thing,
anyone in London during Mysterio's attack
would've been able to see that Spider-Man
was battling all the drones that attacked
the city. Even though Mysterio managed to
fake Peter's voice ordering the drones
to strike, it's hard to believe that not
a single camera in London captured some
footage of the webslinger's good deeds.
Because all Mysterio's framing plot could rely on
was some faked audio and footage of himself merely
saying that Spider-Man was about to attack
him, it all fell apart pretty quickly.
Peter crawled his way out of any legal troubles
with ease, but there's always someone who will
fall for a conspiracy theory. Most of the world
might be convinced of Spider-Man's innocence,
but Jameson and the Bugle's fans are still holding
out for solid proof of Spider-Man's misdeeds.
Peter being outed as Spider-Man causes problems
for just about everyone in his life. To him,
it suddenly looks like the future
he envisioned for himself — happily
studying at college alongside his best friend
and girlfriend — will never become a reality.
On top of that, he and Aunt May have to
shelter in Happy's apartment to hide from
any Spider-Man conspiracy theorists still
out there. Reeling from all the chaos,
Peter thinks of the one person who might be
able to magically make his troubles go away.
When Peter shows up at the Sanctum
Santorum, however, Doctor Strange
informs him that he's no longer the Sorcerer
Supreme. Because the role is so important,
it needed to be filled immediately after
Thanos' Snap turned Strange to dust in the wind.
The only person who could properly fill Doctor
Strange's shoes was, of course, Wong, who in
reality has been working with the magical arts
for longer than Strange himself. While we might've
expected Strange to take his position back when
he un-Blipped, that would hardly be fair to Wong.
Besides, Strange seems perfectly content to focus
on his own pursuits, and Wong must be at least a
little relieved to have some say in what hijinks
Strange gets up to — not that Wong's influence was
able to prevent Strange from breaking open
the multiverse while trying to help Peter.
The first villain to burst onto the scene
is none other than Doc Ock. When he arrives,
he's clearly going for mass destruction, and he
starts off poised to give the MCU's Spider-Man
just as much of a run for his money as he did
in Sam Raimi's "Spider-Man 2" back in 2004.
"Hi. Do we – do I know you?"
Luckily, today's Peter has access to some
tech that Doc Ock's previous foe did not.
When a giant metal tentacle
tears into Peter's Stark suit,
the severed nanobots fuse into Ock's arms
and hand over their control to Peter.
It's great that Peter finally has the upper hand
in his fight, but how were those nanobots able to
interface with Doc Ock's technology? We have to
hand this one to Tony Stark, who's always able
to think one or 10 steps ahead of any problem
he might encounter. This isn't the first time
Stark's tech has been shown to be adaptable and
capable of more or less thinking for itself, and
clearly, Peter's nanobot-powered suit was designed
to change depending on the problems he encounters.
"No Way Home" gives another look at the nanobots'
pseudo-intelligence later in the film when they
slither off a pacified Doc Ock's arms and reform
into a cool looking spider logo on Peter's suit.
Without a doubt, Peter owes this lucky
break to Tony, and now that EDITH is gone,
this might've been the last time his mentor's
technology is able to get him out of a jam.
Anyone who didn't spend the months leading
up to "No Way Home" on an internet sabbatical
knew that Jamie Foxx was returning to
play Electro. After trailers and stills
showed a very different-looking villain than
the one featured in "The Amazing Spider-Man 2,"
everyone began wondering what universe
this Electro really belonged to.
However, when Electro first arrives in the
film, he looks like his old blue self for
just a flash before yellow
electricity floods his body,
and he changes back into a more Jamie
Foxx-looking version of the character.
"I'm happy we got a new, new, a
brand new start. A brand new look."
There are a few different things going on with
Electro's transformation. Outside the world of
the movies, Electro's design in "The Amazing
Spider-Man 2" wasn't particularly popular, so a
reskin was never going to be out of the question.
"No Way Home" could've left the change up to the
magic of the multiverse, but the film actually
takes a bigger step towards a genuine explanation.
Since he first gained his powers, Electro's
body has been entirely composed of the
electrical energy in his world. He says that
the electricity in the MCU feels different — and
more powerful — than that of his home universe.
It doesn't take a scientist to imagine that
drawing on a different form of energy to create
his body could give Electro a different look.
So ... how are all these bad guys alive? This
was one of the biggest questions leading up
to the release of "No Way Home," and the film
doesn't come right out with a solid answer for it.
Each of Spidey's multiversal villains seem to
have been pulled into the MCU from a point very
near their death in their own universes. Doc Ock
and Sandman remember the death of Norman Osborn,
and Electro can recall the Lizard's story, but
none of the villains are aware of their own fate.
Electro gives the clearest answer, as he
states that the last thing he can remember
is Spider-Man using an overloaded power grid
against him in battle. From that, it seems
safe to assume that all the villains were pulled
from the third acts of their respective stories.
The presence of some other important figures
from previous universes raises even more
questions. Both multiversal Spider-Men
explicitly arrive from some point in time
after they were last seen on the big screen.
Obviously, that's great for the audience,
and it gives us a deeper sense
of closure with the characters,
but "No Way Home" doesn't explain why
there's such a discrepancy between the heroes
and the villains. This one will have to be
chalked up to the magic of the multiverse.
One of the best parts about "No Way Home"
is getting to see Peter's friends truly join
in on all the action. Ned and MJ play key
roles in the film, and without their help,
there's no way that Peter would've survived
to see a brand new day. Ned has been Peter's
"man in the chair" since "Homecoming," but
he takes a big step up in this adventure.
When Ned and MJ first arrive at the Sanctum
Santorum, he mentions a rumor in his family that
some of their ancestors had magical abilities.
Later, Ned ends up with Doctor Strange's sling
ring, and sure enough, he's able to use it
to open multiple portals throughout the film.
Ned is astounded by his new abilities, but
his grandmother — who presumably could have
some deeper insight into the family's
magical past — hardly blinks an eye.
We already know that magical abilities aren't
necessarily linked to lineage. Unless it's later
revealed that Doctor Strange has some magic
in his family's past, he became a sorcerer
through nothing more mysterious than rigorous
study and hard work. It's possible that some
latent ability in Ned's genetics allowed him to
focus some energy through a sling ring with ease,
but without further instruction, it's
unlikely that he'll become a true sorcerer.
Of course, we have to wonder, does
Ned even remember using magic now?
When Spider-Man villains from alternate
universes start arriving in the MCU,
Peter is determined to help Doctor Strange
capture them and return them to their own worlds.
That all changes when Peter discovers that
almost all the villains he's captured died
in their universes. Knowing that returning them
home means sending them to their imminent deaths,
Peter resolves to find a way to save them all.
The simple solution for saving the villains is to
"cure" them of their various abilities. After all,
if Spider-Man's foes aren't superpowered, they
won't need to fight the hero to the death.
It takes some multiversal assistance
— and some serious sacrifice — for
Peter to find a cure for each of
the five baddies he's up against.
Ultimately, he's able to de-power everyone
before repairing the cracks in the universe
and sending them all home. How does that
impact the original universe of each villain?
"No Way Home" doesn't show what happens in the
Raimi-verse and Webb-verse when everyone returns,
but the changes are undoubtedly huge. No
one would remember their time in the MCU,
but all the villains would be returned to good
guy status — or at least neutral guy status — well
before they died. Because Harry Osborn didn't
need to seek revenge for his father's death,
is he still alive in the Raimi-verse? Without
the final battle against Electro taking place,
is Gwen Stacy alive in the Webb-verse?
All that could be on the table now,
but we'll have to wait for future
announcements to know for sure.
At the climax of "No Way Home," the multiverse
is collapsing, and Doctor Strange is doing
everything in his power to prevent all of reality
from being pulled into the confines of the MCU.
Clearly, whatever is coming through from alternate
universes would be immensely destructive,
but Strange plays coy about
the specifics of the danger.
"They are coming," he tells Peter, but he
doesn't bother to explain who "they" are.
"They're starting to come
through, and I can't stop them."
Two possibilities seem most likely here.
First, Marvel's "What If?" on Disney+ has
already shown that there's no shortage of
dangerous characters out in the multiverse.
On the other hand, "Eternals" recently introduced
a whole slew of new dangers into the MCU.
In Strange's struggle against the multiverse,
mysterious glowing figures are only briefly
shown peeking through the cracks of reality, but
the visuals had a striking resemblance to some of
the Celestials we've already seen. Considering
how dangerous a single Celestial can be,
an army of them would be more than enough
to make Strange sweat bullets. Either way,
it seems very likely that "The Multiverse
of Madness" will give us further hints.
"Venom: Let There Be Carnage" sent
shockwaves through the nerd world
with its end-credits scene. Eddie Brock and
Venom were transported into the MCU just in
time to see Peter Parker's secret identity
revealed on the news by Mysterio and J.
Jonah Jameson. We all wondered if this meant
Venom was officially part of the MCU and whether
or not he would team up with the other baddies
in "No Way Home" to create the Sinister Six.
However, Eddie Brock and his favorite
parasite made only a brief appearance
in the film's mid-credits scene. Eddie
is seen at a bar getting up to speed
on the incredible events of the MCU, but
then he's transported away when Doctor
Strange closes the multiverse ... though
a small piece of symbiote is left behind.
The scene raises more questions than it answers.
All we know for now is that a small piece of
Venom has officially made its way into the MCU.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.